hi everybody today is going to be
basically for the ladies because we're
going to work on in quarters
these are a common topic in technique
but why not it's lots of fun
first we will start with our warm-up
then we will do a preparation exercise
for the cocteau standing then we will
lay down on the floor
and we'll do two sets of exercises to
practice the movements of our legs in
the air first we will do it straight and
then we will do the ground then we will
practice their copter one more time
using support so that we can jump and at
the very end we will do something for
the men we are going to use the
structure of the cocktail so who can
come up with some interesting adornments
that we can put in our steps ok let's
start ok one month it's going to be
exactly like the class before but I'm
going to know every exercise with you so
we start with it together a straight
posture breathe relax let the weight of
your body come down to the floor and
establish shoulder rotations backwards
remember the knees the elbows used only
the shoulders okay and we go eight times
one two three slowing four five six
seven and eight the next one is circles
with their arms so we start with arms
down then we point their eyes forward
then up and then we open them to the
sides keeping them straight at this
point we open the chest and then down
again and we repeat we are going to do
eight times okay
one keep the shoulders down two three
keep your arm straight at all times four
five six big circle seven and eight
okay the next one is stretches for the
side of the torso
so we point one to the ceiling then the
Honda is when the leg slides down the
leg until you can touch the side of your
knee more or less then you hold the
stretch three seconds and then you use
the hand that is up to pull yourself up
again and then we repeat so we're going
to look for times each side one go down
hold it hold it
[Music]
and the last one for go down hold it up
for go down hold it up
okay the next one is notations with the
door so we open the legs we bend the
knees slightly we keep the heat on the
hip looking forward we make a circle
with the arms and we turn after slope
left and right and we'll 16 times 8 and
8 okay one two three four five six eight
more one two three four five six seven
eight
very good the next one we stretch names
we put our thumbs behind the head and
then we bend forward until our torso is
parallel with the floor and then we
continue going down and we bow three
times when our heads 1 2 3 and then we
return to the position ok
[Music]
five eight final balance balance balance
okay the next one we keep our legs open
underneath straight we grab our hips
with our hands and little circles with
the hip so we start back then we move
the hip to the side at this point you
should feel a stretch on the inside of
this leg then forward then do the other
side
feel the stretch here and then down a
back side and this is a whole circle and
we'll eight on each direction okay so we
start and one two and three and four
five six seven six seven and eight
keep the knees straight yeah change one
two three four five six seven eight okay
and the last exercise we put our feet
well again
legs partner and whether we Bend our
knees in relaxed and we bounce it
one two three we stretch the knees we
push the floor down and we hold this
position for 3 seconds on the toes and
then we go down and this is one petition
so we will do 8 ok we start one go up
hold and now to bounce bounce bounce
stretch and down three bounce bounce
bounce up hold it up for bounce bounce
bounce
hold it down five bounce bounce bounce
up hold it down six
bounce bounce bounce up hold it down
seven bounce bounce bounce
hold it down last one
bounce bounce bounce hold it okay we're
ready with the warm-up is Linux okay
we're going to do now preparation
exercise for the encoder know the
structure of an encoder is a jump on one
leg then four columns in the air and
then landing on the other day and the
formulas are LEDs are one wave front
then two columns back each leg and then
Alice polio front so this is the first
exercise
we'll start with feet together I put my
weight on the right foot and then I do a
ballet affront with the left leg change
the weight whatever with right leg
change the weight or little back with
left leg changing weight or little fun
with right leg okay now the technique
for this is to relax the neck relax the
knee and relax the foot joint so that
when you do it Folio you can snap like
yeah relax the front of the leg
especially for the back wheels
yeah now usually I would do this
exercise with music but I don't want a
copyright strike on the videos so
instead of that I'm going to use a
metronome ladies to have a reference for
the rhythm this metronome is from the
chord is a non-oil I have four years and
I really recommend you to get one of
these because although you can use easy
to train sometimes it's good to use a
metronome because it's the most
effective way to improve the position of
your timing because you don't have
anything else to distract you have
leaves music honorees arrangement
singing is just the pure rhythm so it
forces you to be very very precise with
your movements and when your timing is
off is very easy to feel it when you are
working with a madman now if you don't
have something like this you can for
example use an app on your phone the
program with metronome
the phonies many lots of things in the
background and sometimes the beats are
not really exact with the timing you can
feel some beats that are being loud
so it's not my preferred option another
possibility is to use free online up
that runs in your browser then you have
a metronome on your browser but the
problem of course is that you need a
computer there so this is very practical
I recommend to wear this you can find it
very easily in any shop or online so I
will put a link on the description so
you can find it now the way I have set
this is two beats per bar it sounds like
this firstly secondly firstly secondly
because this is usually the time
signature of the music - beach club and
the tempo right now is quite slow is 58
beats per minute because this tempo
it's very well with many tags from this
high for example and when you do a very
slow version we're going to do one
movement per beat of the change change
change or lame okay so we go four times
so let's say together
[Music]
okay that was easy
now they're going to lead to the other
side we are going to start with your
body comes with a right yeah we do it
together ready okay so now we're going
to do the same exercise but twice as
fast
now instead of raising the tempo on the
metronome I'm going to set it up so that
it gives me an extra subdivision for
each beat
clemmy's now we have this extra
subdivision do and this is a supervision
of the week when we are going to change
our way I'll show you it's going to be
later change
one day it'll change okay thank you so
let's get together we started a body up
with drugs with the left leg and with
eight times
okay now we the same cut to the other
side we started from starting in the
right okay now of course if you want you
can repeat this block again if you have
a metonym you can challenge yourself and
resident
60 BPM 65 BPM 70 BPM faster and one
observation if you're a woman doing this
I recommend you to do this exercise with
high heels because you are crossing your
free foot in front of your standing leg
very often if you point the foot your
heel will be looking directly towards
your leg and if you're not careful you
can scratch the skin on your standing
leg with your heel when you do this
movement especially you do it fast so I
recommend it to wait to do it with high
heels and went into the slow curve in
the first one we did try to measure the
distance that you need so that you can
injure yourself if you have problems
with balance you can do these exercise
supporting yourself now wall in front of
you like this that's not good but yes be
careful with your heels
okay now let's go to the next book okay
so the next book is an exercise for any
copters laying down on the floor and
gasps remember keep your heels so that
you practice to learn without scratching
the front of your leg with the heel yeah
and it's going to be like this we're
going to lay down on the floor like this
and we are going to lift the legs and
practice the movement of the copter with
the legs up in the air now because this
can be tiring
I recommend you
do not do this in the middle of your
personal because it's going to kill the
lower back yeah you're going to feel
pain so what I recommend you is laying
on the floor as flat as you can and then
try to push your stomach towards the
floor sink it down so they already flat
and then extend your arms to the sides
back down so you have a very good
support okay and then extend the legs
forward up on zero position and then the
exercise Israelis believe front with the
left leg so we cross the ladies then
we're going to switch the knees we bend
the right leg and we stretch the left
leg
that's the bolero back then we switch
Denise we stretch the right leg left the
second model back and then we stretch
the left and we tend arrived and we do
the last volley of front and then we'll
return to zero position yeah
so it's front back back front zero okay
now we're going to use a metronome again
same tempo same time signature we're
going to do it slowly so we're going to
do one change the beat one come and
we're going to do it four times on each
side so get ready to turn the legs zero
position
[Music]
okay great now we're going to do it
twice as fast so I'm going to do like
before I'm going to set the metronome so
that it plays an expressive division
between beats and now the idea is to do
the same sequence but twice as fast so
one one okay so we're going to do it
eight times on each side
okay so prepare your position flatten
storm on the floor but flat cars open
race let's see opposition I will stop
one
[Music]
so that was the straight version now the
next part is going to be to do it in a
random direction okay so now we are
going to do the same sequence but
instead of moving our legs straight we
are going to move them in a circle now
let's see how the circle works so if you
use only the name your leg will move up
and down in a straight line right but if
you use this joint now like this your
leg moves sideways so if you use knee
and heel together
you can do a cell phone with the food
yeah a separ is a combination of the
knee and the hip working together so
this is the first exercise you can try
the support circles on one direction one
to try to draw a circle near three and
four now change the direction one two
three and four
yeah you have to see a circle in front
of you now change the leg and let's try
again the same thing
this was circle one two three four and
now it seems the direction one two three
four yeah remember it has to coordinate
knee and sheep together to make this
happen okay
now how does this set by the up work on
the doctor well it's a nice when you
start you're here okay so now when you
change the legs to go from the left
front today were little but you don't
use only the knees
what you is this wood doesn't go
straight down like this it goes in a
circle ladies in a circle and this wood
doesn't move straight up like this it
goes also in a circle so both movements
are valleys this is the first change
from away from whatever and if you see
the feet are always about always about
now when you change from the first molar
back to the sacrum Oliver you can
usually
many of these you continue with the
circle doing like this so the feet never
touch each other they always keep a
distance like this and then you continue
the circle to finish with the last body
forward yeah so you're always doing a
circle and the feet always keep a
distance with each other okay so now we
are going to do for a cup drops slowly
so we are going to set the metronome
again 258 bpm
two beats per bar and we are going to
[Music]
remember the position yeah the back is
flat on the floor the stomach is pushed
down towards the floor so then you have
a lot of contact then you open the arms
to the sides come down so that you have
a very good basis work and then we're
going to start with these Willie and
then we are going to follow the middle
we will do one two three four and then
return to zero position and then again
one two three four return to your
position
okay let's do it four times starting
with three four one two three four
[Music]
- okay okay so for the formal times 1 2
3 4 0 1 2 3 4 0 1 2
four zero one two three four zero okay
now we are going to do it any more times
starting together stand with the right
okay prepare the position flat stomach
open the arms legs one two three four
one two one two one two three four zero
okay this was let's continue with the
next one okay so now we are going to
practice the cocktail with a jump and
for that of course we need some kind of
support so we can stay longer in the air
and I have this device it's for doing
fitness exercises is very practical
because
very strong is very stable you can grab
it and then work with your legs as long
as you what yeah
but of course I will put a link in the
description so that you can finally
stand by for nine if you have it but for
some of us don't have this thing so for
that we can use something else we can
use two chairs then you can support
yourself on them and practice now they
are this is not so stable so it's a bit
dangerous because for example if you are
not pushing directly down you can have
an accident so in order to make the
chairs more stable you can put something
heavy on top of them for example I have
these two weights now it's much more
secure to balance yourself
remember the other problem is that it
might be uncomfortable to grab this thin
edge of the chair for a long time it
might be painful for your hand so for
that the solution is very easy you just
need like this you grab them now it's
much easier more comfortable
without the chairs yeah anyway this is
how you can practice the cocktail at
home safely but if you can I recommend
to get the other device I'm going to
show it with the other device so that
you can see my legs more clear okay
okay so I'm up with this and now we are
going to practice the cotton drying the
jungle so ready to start in the middle
with the feet together between your
chairs or if you have these and then
we're going to put the left foot forward
and the right foot is going to be our
jump leg so when we jump up of course we
use the arms to help us stay up then we
are going to do the first body at the
same time one that is one you can try
this a few times one then we're going to
change the legs change the legs and
change legs and then land on the left
leg and then prepare again the position
yeah
so we jump for the front Oreo bubbly
bubbly front blunt
one more time jump back with the
metronome four times to each side so
[Music]
that's our temple we're going to jump
okay jump now it's sweet they're jumping
with the right leg
what happened with the left
[Music]
okay okay now we're going to do the
sting but twice as fast because that's
more realistic all you have to do when
you jump in the air so I'm going to set
the metronome up so that it plays me one
more sub division between the beats that
I already have that's that's the speed
now now we're going to use so we're
going to do it eight times now and we're
going to jump on the right leg
so prepared
[Music]
okay now we're going to do to the next
time we jump with the left leg we do the
first pulling forward with the right and
then we do the 4 flex handling on the
right and we're going to do it exactly
with this speed ready we do together
[Music]
hey okay right now one last tip is that
when you do a four-hour many cocktail
for real there is one more movement that
you have to add to it but that's very
difficult to practice alone or language
because what happens is that it's not
only that you do a circle with your feet
to make it look round you also have to
use your hip like this yeah
so usually what happens is that the
woman starts the helicopter
Wendy's yeah she jumps she does the
first volley like this and then from the
stick from the First Folio
back to the second for their buck she
changes her hip and then she goes on the
last column for and she lands yeah so
between the first volley go back and the
second will airlock she twists her hips
like in a rotary what happened yeah so
I'll show you once more you start the
helicopter with the side looking float
and then you jump on your back leg I
give you the First Folio
one forward then body back then change
volume back and then where you're from
and then like the problem is that if
you're supporting yourself
this is very difficult to do this change
of hip without bumping into the chairs
so it's really difficult very so this is
something you really need to do with a
partner and if your partner leads
helicopters right when he lets you and
you are doing the first one in your back
he will give you a lead so that your hip
changes rotates in there and then you
will have the includes to do and really
round spectacularly but this is
something that you didn't need to do
with a partner at least with this you
can prepare your legs and you can
prepare already the movements and when
you go to the partner you already know
exactly what you have to do with your
legs when you jump okay so let's go to
the last club
okay in this last part we will take the
structure very cocksure of the woman and
when we use it to find some interesting
adornments for the mind so let's
remember the doctor was a step back with
a jump and going forward and then after
these two volumes back and then a last
wave forward that lands again on the
floor with a step forward
yeah so step back with jump wheelie or
forward a little bubbly robot will live
forward landing step forward to finish
okay so let's take out the two boleros
back we won't use them we will only use
the two legs forward these and this and
for the first sequence that we're going
to see we are also going to take out the
jump we want John we will just
anyway so the structure that we have
left them is like this a step back with
our lair forward without the jump then a
change of weight the second bullet
forward and then a step forward
yeah so without the adornments the step
would be back change wake and front
which is a very common movement in
jungle but change way and float so with
governments is going to be but bolero
change way Polly front this polymer is
very low if you want to do this and this
you can do it if you want but I consider
that for this environment
especially for the man it looks very
elegant if you do a low value like this
in which the middle of the path of your
lower leg this point touches the middle
of the front of the other lower leg this
one so you touch these two points
together and then for the other all your
enemies so this is the sequence we are
going to do but volure flow change way
all your frog and float okay so again
let's use the metronome for this 58 BPM
two beats per bar
it sounds ladies and with an extra suit
division in each beat yeah
okay so I'm going to put the metronome
here nice trick I found and then we're
going to like slowly it's going to be
like this God for a change for you don't
change but or later change for you okay
welcome to the 8 times
now you don't need to change orientation
I'm changing my scoffs well my driving
light is always facing the camera - okay
[Music]
okay yeah this is the last one we are
going to do is we're going to take the
tongue of the
so when with the first step but I'm the
First Folio we are also going to do a
little jump remember that when men do
things these kind of things
the movements are very very tiny so it's
not a big jump now it's just a very
small jump like this boom yeah just
barely leaving the floor boom that's
with the first volume so it's going to
be one is the step two is the Bolero
with the jump then three is the change
of weight after the jump four is the
other color forward and then we finish
with a step forward so it's one two
three four one one two three four one
okay so let's do it again in the slow
version with just one extra supervision
in each beat okay so I'm going to show
you first watch and then we do it
together okay so it's going to be ladies
one two three four one is very slow one
two three four one it's an exercise for
box one two three four okay so eight
times together
[Music]
okay now we will be twice as fast so to
play now the sequence will be like okay
okay remember one two three four okay
[Music]
one two three four one two three four
okay let's make 8 times 1 2 3 4 1 1 2 3
4 1 1 2 3 4 1 1 2 3 4 1 1 2 3 4 ok good
so this was the last section I hope you
have fun it's a lot of material today
but I hope it helps you and of course
you can repeat each section of this
video and challenge yourself try other
temples try faster drive slower which is
also difficult and practice practice
practice and see you in the next video
thank you very much